[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and job
or as I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where me
and my brother John answer your
questions give you dubious advice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon hey John how are
you this week I'm alright I just came
from my two-year-old daughter Alice's a
parent-teacher conference analyzing her
progress in school thus far hmm geez you
know she's just turned 2 so it's a
little early to declare victory but
there was widespread agreement that she
is a genius that's great news although
they'll also probably possibly troubling
like you a genius can come up with it
with its own with its own troubles sure
but she's the smiley kind of genius
she's she's pleasant she's social she
knows essentially every word no I
couldn't be I couldn't be prouder of
Alice I have to tell you there is
nothing more surreal than being in a
parent-teacher conference for a
two-year-old child because of course
there's very little to say she eats with
both her hands that's that's the level
of analysis that we can get into that's
awesome but otherwise things are okay
here in Indianapolis I'm still
struggling a bit to find a new
medication regimen that will work for me
with my my mental health disorders but
otherwise I'm well the family as well
yeah Sarah is in Washington DC right now
for the art assignment so I get to be
with the kids 24 hours a day which is uh
you know it's a thing it's it's it's
it's mostly fun and really really
rewarding I'm lucky that I like being a
dad how are you Hank
I'm good we just had our VidCon like
like big planning meeting with all of
the VidCon staff so that that ended
literally moments before we started
recording this podcast which is why I
was a little late and John has been
waiting for me sorry John and I assume
this
is that VidCon will be great next year
and that everyone should get their
tickets now at VidCon com VidCon will
indeed be great next year and everyone
should indeed go get their tickets at
VidCon dot-com now available at VidCon
com speaking if we're chanc it's not
just it's not just the time of year when
VidCon tickets become available it's
that magic time of year that in
vlogbrothers world we call Pizza myths
it is currently pizza mess a two-week
period in which you and I make videos
back and forth every day and also there
are Pizza John items available at
dftba.com that you can pre-order but
only only during Pizza miss so if you
would like a pizza John shirt if you
don't know what a pizza John sure it is
don't worry you're in a huge majority of
Americans and other people but if you
would like a pizza John shirt or a
Leaning Tower of Pisa John shirt or any
number of other Pizza John items
including Pizza John shoelaces you can
check that out at dftba.com Hank today I
don't think we need to do the sponsoring
thing because I think we've just
actually had a sponsored podcast but
when how what oh yes yes bye-bye VidCon
and by Pizza --mess yes do you have a
short poem for us I do it's called
poetry it's a special poem just for you
Hank by Mary Ann Moore again the title
is poetry you must bear in mind the
title poetry as I read you the poem I do
dislike it reading it however with a
perfect contempt for it one discovers in
it after all a place for the genuine
poetry by Marianne Moore published in
the complete poems Marion Moore in 1967
where do you think cynicism comes from
John well the word comes from the
ancient Greeks where where do I think
the idea of cynicism comes from well I
mean I I think it comes from I think it
comes from suspicion I think that we are
we are born rightly suspicious of one
another and of the universe suspicious
that perhaps the universe is not
overwhelmingly interested in what
happens to us all right let's do a
question that was my question and John
answered it
god this is such a great comedy podcast
I just easy you know I listen to comedy
podcasts all the time and what I always
find myself thinking is well this one's
actually funny and that's the big that's
their big struggle advantage over well
you know John it's sometimes it's okay
to be structurally at a disadvantage and
I'm fine with that you know I think
we've put ourselves in a place where we
are incapable of success in this
particular genre and that's alright
growing outside of our our current
growth seems unnecessary to me I want
this to be super indie I wanted to be an
indie underground comedy podcast that
isn't funny it's like wait and that's
the only way to do it is just to dot not
be funny yeah that's the the most indie
comedy is the comedy that doesn't even
try to be at all funny one of my
favorite comedy performances of all time
was Andy Kaufman reading the entirety of
The Great Gatsby
yeah we're just we're not as good as
Andy Kaufman oh yes but but we can
endeavor to try and just to instill
lists our podcast is comedy and then
talk about existential difficulties and
and the origins of cynicism and boom
boom like you know a tenth of the way to
Andy Kaufman I'd saying like maybe a
thousandth but let's answer a question
from a listener okay this one is from
Aaron who says dear Hank and John as a
proper adult I think I would love some
dubious advice so I've been to
University and come out the other side
and one thing I now know is how much I
still don't know by study has always
been focused on one area art and
curatorship and education but I want to
start learning about other areas of life
and I don't know where to get started
where do you start learning about
science and poetry and language and
maths as an adult especially if those
subjects are your worst at school well
that's sort of the life story of my
education I think most of it happened
after college or at least outside of my
two areas of study English literature
and religion because I paid so little
attention to school when I was in it
it was rather wasted on me unfortunately
so for me like the best way in
was books I don't think that's true for
everyone I think there's great like
YouTube channels now I think you could
follow hopefully crash course could be
helpful but also there's things like
minutephysics and and lots of other
channels but for me it was books and
there are lots and lots and lots of
books that seek to introduce you to
physics or to biology or to chemistry
and they can be somewhat tough going at
first but I don't know that's that that
was my way in Hank how about you I agree
and I yes what the difficulty is always
that sometimes you will read something
and you would be like well that is
clearly above my paygrade and and so can
we take a few steps back finding the
things that are really written for the
layperson to sort of create the
structure on which you can you can build
your knowledge of a topic is always the
hard part I tend to actually end up
doing that on Wikipedia a lot and I like
I will just get interested in a topic
and I will read the Wikipedia page and
the nice thing about Wikipedia is that
like at any moment you can click on the
thing that you don't understand
and you don't you have to type it into
the search bar and you'll be reading the
article you're like okay now I have to
get I don't quite get this but there's
this thing is clearly the part of this
that I don't understand and so I need to
understand that part I also think that
it is really valuable to look at what
you do understand and use that as like a
structure on which to build into other
areas and so sort of like a you know a
mold spreading across a piece of bread
as it you know so that you can you can
take over the whole piece of bread but
you start from where you're at you know
you start from where you already have a
deep understanding where you've
penetrated the bread and are extracting
nutrients from the bread and and you
understand that deeply and then you move
into other areas more on the surface and
then go deeper until you've consumed the
entire piece of bread and made it
inedible to man yeah I don't know if
you're not allowed to eat mold I think
you can't eat mold I think it just might
make you sick yeah so if you for
instance if you've studied you know art
and curatorship you might have studied
something involving you know perspective
in Renaissance painting or whatever and
that can be a way into
big interesting questions in geometry
like an example of this for me is that I
read a David Foster Wallace book
everything and more because I really
like David Foster Wallace but the book
was about infinity and how some infinite
sets are larger than other infinite sets
which is an important part of my novel
The Fault in Our Stars and even though a
lot of the math in the book was over my
head and in the end it turned out some
of the math was in fact wrong I was
really really fascinated by the way that
David Foster Wallace could link things
that I already knew about in literature
or in folklore to things that I didn't
know about in for instance calculus yeah
and set theory yeah and I find the more
that you know about something if you
start small the more that you know the
more you want to know and the more
interesting it all gets at every level
okay we have a question from Louisa this
is a vitally important one and very
time-sensitive Dear John and Hank I need
to have my wisdom teeth removed in the
near future do you have any tips on how
to prepare for and recover from oral
surgery well do not forget to have a
person the person who's picking you up
and taking you home because of course
you cannot drive home to have their cell
phone ready to film you know that you
can have that for the archives
don't necessarily upload it on to
YouTube but it is a nice thing to show
around at dinner parties because there's
nothing like being completely completely
trashed on oral surgery medication that
is the number one thing you have to
remember is to videotape the immediate
aftermath of you waking up it's vitally
important there are some other things
you know making sure that you don't get
a an infection that kills you it cetera
but videotaping the moments after you
wake up little surgery absolutely vital
so you've come to the right place
Louise as you can already tell from
Hanks excellent advice because I've had
11 oral surgeries so I am an expert in
in preparing for and recovering from
oral surgery the first thing that I
would say is that getting your wisdom
teeth taken out as oral surgeries go not
that big of a deal
I wouldn't worry about it too much
unless you've got some serious impaction
or something basically you're gonna want
to take the pain medication as soon as
you're supposed to so you can stay ahead
of the pain and you probably won't need
it for more than a day or two you're
gonna eat some grits and some milkshakes
don't suck through a straw listen to
your doctor and just change out the the
bloody gauze now and again and you're
gonna be fine
it's nothing compared to what I've had I
had I had a moment where I after my
wisdom teeth got taken out where there
was some food stuck in the hole yeah
don't do your best not to have that
happen so stay off the solid foods for
as long as they tell you to and use that
little that little injecting thing fill
it up with with room with body
temperature water yeah uh and and make
sure you clean out your your bloody
holes just remember to clean out your
bloody holes Louisa and you'll be just
fine and and also I will say make sure
that you have the person who's filming
you be a person you can trust
yep yeah because you don't want them
uploading that to YouTube without your
permission so Hank when I had my wisdom
teeth taken out my when I woke up my
oral surgeon said are you a religious
man and I said yeah you know somewhat
and he said I asked because when I gave
you the sedation you crossed yourself
once which seemed pretty normal but then
you continued to cross yourself for
three or four minutes until finally a
nurse just had to hold your hand down
get into my mouth because I was too busy
crossing hands the power of Christ
compels you yeah yeah like you were
unconscious yeah yeah yeah yeah but I
really really really wanted to make sure
as I was going down that I was well
settled with the Lord yeah
I after my oral after my wisdom teeth
came out and well Rhett watched the
entire Godfather trilogy which is still
have still a trilogy that I have not
seen as far as I'm concerned because I
remember nothing of it well I can
summarize it for you the first two
movies are arguably the two best films
ever made
the third movie is maybe the worst movie
of all time yeah well that is
disappointing so just watch the first
two all right John we've got another
question this one is from Odie who asks
dear Hank and John every home room in
school someone from my home room is
responsible for bringing in food because
lunch is often wild later in the day we
somebody brought in a bag of potato
chips recently and I ate a lot of them
and well it was eating them one of my
friends criticized me for a right eating
style saying that I should eat potato
chips with only two fingers instead of
three so that the potato chip dust
concentrates more on two fingers and it
is easier and more fun to lick it off i
refuted this no no no no no no no no no
no no no what's wrong
Oh God first off oh my god your dinner
is burning right we're like halfway
through the podcast I completely forgot
well we are way this is a different
podcast that was last podcast this
person has already set up their cell
phone to scream for us I know but
somebody's dinner could still be burning
Hank but we have to stop this question
right now you do not ever lick your
fingers period ever no no John and I are
gonna disagree on this one I'm licking
my finger right now oh good we're doing
it oh god are you are you currently in
the shower remotely acceptable have you
just applied Purell you do not unless
you are absolutely certain that your
hands are quite clean you do not lick
your fingers hey can I tell you the
thing that bothers me most about the
National Football League which is a
sport here in the United States in which
large men play with it with a ball that
mostly with their hands anyway what
bothers me most is there's this position
called the quarterback and and every
single NFL quarterback immediately
before the hiking of the ball they lick
their fingers all of them it's the most
hole
fiying thing because these are men who
are sweating they're touching other
people's sweat and blood and god only
knows what else and then they lick their
fingers before every single play it's a
miracle that all of them don't have
norovirus every week I'm sorry to feel
so passionately about this but I just
think we need to stop this question
right now and and and just say it is not
okay to lick the potato chip dust off
your fingers I think that one of the
principal joys in life is being able to
ingest bacteria and not die and that's
something that we do constantly every
day if you eat food lick your lips touch
things if you're you know you went in
the White River Inn and drank literally
thousands of people's feces John it's
okay
hopefully just hundreds but at least
hundreds probably thousands it's it's
alright it is okay - it is okay
that we you know have this relationship
and we have an immune system and it
functions very well and if you do not
have an immune system problem you can
lick the potato chip dust off of your
fingers and John you're going to argue
against me and that's okay we're gonna
agree to disagree on this one and I'm
gonna continue to like you as a person I
think that that might be the most
dubious advice that you have ever
offered in there you know our history of
this beautiful fingers since the
beginning of time it's literally a
cliche finger licking good it has in the
three word cliche the description of
what finger lickin is and the word good
it's not bad do you know what all of
those people from the very beginning of
time who licked their fingers haven't
come they died of various diseases that
were not caused by finger licking
they're dead that's right you were you
were on the right track but they're all
dead every single one of them their
finger lickin dead
let's let's move on dude II respectfully
just just don't just don't it doesn't
matter if you're licking two fingers or
three fingers just don't lick the
fingers you know okay well we're I agree
that it doesn't matter which fingers
fingers you're lickin John and I can
agree on that point but woody has the
second part of the question which was
how can we agree on important things
like who should be the next president or
if darth vader was ultimately good when
we can't even agree on how many fingers
we should eat potato chips with oh I see
so the underlying question is like given
how difficult it is to come to a
consensus on very basic things like
whether we should lick our fingers to
death
should we how are we ever going to come
to consensus on more complicated topics
the answer to that question I think is
with a very large data sample like with
a very large it in a very large
conversation that is inclusive so I
think so the wisdom of the crowd yeah I
think that we govern better and we live
better when we learn together and listen
to each other and include as many voices
as possible in these big conversations
about what we should do and why and I
think by the way that if we included
every possible voice there would be
widespread agreement that you shouldn't
lick your fingers after eating potato
chips but let's move on or we could just
compromise average it out and say that
you should be eating with one and a half
fingers and that is almost precisely the
argument that the United States Congress
people make against compromise what are
we gonna cut everybody's fingers off
just to where everybody's only gonna
have one and a half fingers at the end
of this conversation I threw my pen I
was angry yes it's not a sound argument
but it is one that I often hear from
Congress people let's move on to another
question Hank this one's from Alex he
writes Dear John and Hank this is a
pressing question that has been haunting
me for the last few days
0:04 days I was expecting year
is why our bananas hexagons well I would
argue that bananas themselves are not
hexagons that they're rather circular
but the peel yes rather hexagonal
hexagons achill hexagonal Professor
McGonagall hexagonal oh and and yeah I
don't know I don't know I don't like I
want a banana in front of me right now
because I'm not sure that bananas are
hexagonal or that they certainly I'm not
sure that they would be universally
hexagonal I mean there are lots of
hexagons in nature though it is a very
strong shape it is the shape that it it
is good at having a a large surface area
to volume ratio why is it oh oh that's
why so if something is like a shape that
appears a lot in nature it's often
because it's a strong shape explain that
to me well I mean like for example if
Abby wants to build a honeycomb the they
want that thing to be structurally sound
sure and and and and you know like grids
of hexagons just are really good at at
stress load so they like they have lots
of different little points where the
where the stress get like if you
compress them it's like there's no one
point that has a ton of stress on it it
shares the load between a lot of
different points and that but like yeah
the the the the reappearance of certain
shapes over and over again in nature is
very interesting and very weird and and
that it follows you know mathematical
patterns that we established before we
found them in nature is very interesting
and and it's sort of above my paygrade
isn't that what john nash wrote his
nobel prize-winning
paper on i do not think so okay well
what if what what what do I know
um so Hank let me ask you a question
this may be a stupid question but if a
hexagon is good does that mean that an
octagon is better and it's just that
like bees aren't smart enough to have
figured that out well first it would not
be bees it would be just sort of the
process of evolution
oh that that quote-unquote figured that
out just trial and error and and what
worked and sticking with what works but
I don't know I don't know I don't think
that an octagon would be better there
might be a shape that would be better
but hexagons are really good at stress
load and at at like the amount of
material you have to use per per thing
in nature so let's see we use less stuff
to have more alright so basically we're
gonna have to get a real expert in
industrial engineering on this podcast
to answer that question but the
important thing that I have to say here
is I don't know and I think that it's
important that I'd say that more often
okay good I will look forward to finding
out about that next week in the meantime
we need to answer a couple more
questions from our listeners before we
get to the amazing news from AFC
Wimbledon and also the news from Mars
which is a cold dead rock in the middle
of space I do have another question it's
from Monica who asks dear Hank and John
for my senior year of high school
I decided to take AP government class so
far I've very much enjoyed the class and
discussions that we have I took the
class because I feel that as an American
it's important to understand our
government and politics I'm very
interested in voting in the upcoming
presidential election I know both of you
feel strongly about voting so I was
hoping you could explain the process
that I will have to go through in order
to vote including everything leading up
to voting and the actual action of
voting itself thank you so Monica you
get to something important about voting
which is that it's stressful and it's a
little bit overwhelming and it feels
complicated and often it is a little bit
complicated especially in the United
States perhaps eat arguably much more
complicated than it needs to be because
there are forces in the world that would
like a person that is as young as
yourself not to vote yeah and those
forces are at times very powerful so it
depends on where you live in some places
you can register to vote on the day that
you vote on some places you can vote
early and so you have to look up the
rules in your particular state but in
most places you have to register to vote
you
do that at a DMV or at a library I like
to do it at the library because then you
get to get books as well so it's kind of
a double win and or you can do it as a
post-office lots of places you can
register to vote you can also do it
through the mail I think it depends on
where you are yeah also the nice thing
about all of this is that we now live in
a world where you can type in the name
of your state and register to vote and
oftentimes you can just do it on the
internet so that's true yeah there's
always the internet I keep forgetting
and if the energy yeah because because
when we registered to vote you literally
couldn't like in order to figure out how
to register to vote like I only did it
because there was like a table at my
college that was like register to vote
and I was like yeah yeah I'll do that
and that's kind of crazy that you it
used to be so hard and now it's quite
easy and even if you can't do it on the
internet it will tell you how to do it
yeah and give you a number of options
for how to register to vote if you've
never registered and there's nothing bad
about registering to vote people will
say that oh now you're gonna get jury
duty no you will get jury duty whether
or not you register to vote it's not
like you're registering for jury duty
you that is a completely different list
of names and and then as far as the
process goes I am now at the point in my
life and luckily Montana has really good
laws with regards to this that I don't
go to the polls anymore now I think that
one person like every person should do
that at least once in their life like go
do the thing but now I just absentee
vote even though I'm not absentee and
and that is there's a word for that that
escapes me at the moment but it's just
early voting early voting they to send
you an envelope in the mail you sign up
for them to send you the envelope you do
it you fill it out there's a little
thing to sign on the thing make sure I
did this and not some person who lives
in my house and then you sign on the
outside of the envelope and you follow
all the instructions and it's you get
time to think about it and you know if
you don't know what one of the ballot
initiatives is you could look it up on
the internet it o process if you do a
lot of research takes like an hour and
and like to like that's obviously not
it's gonna be what you do if you go to
the poll and you like have to like look
at the ballot what its gonna be before
you do it and do all that research
beforehand
so early voting is really nice as for
your state allows it and I I suggest
that you know going to the polls is a
unique experience and and one that I'm
glad that I have done but early voting
is super easy and not stressful at all
yeah so I find going to the polls a
little bit stressful because you have to
stand in line and stuff but you can
bring a sample ballot with you that's
what I do every year I bring a sample
ballot with me that I print out from the
internet and I have filled out my sample
ballot already in advance so I know the
answer to all of the questions about who
I'm going to vote for before I get to
the voting booth now I will say that I
made a mistake in my first presidential
vote which was embarrassingly late in my
life it was in 2004 I made a mistake and
I just raised my hand and said I have
made a mistake I have voted for the
wrong person for president and someone
came and they spoiled my ballot and they
allowed me you know and then and then
you get to vote again it was a little
bit embarrassing but I learned that it's
in fact very easy and not a big deal in
general all of these things are
stressful because they are unknowns but
they are not difficult and there are
people there at every step of the way
who want you to vote and the most
important thing I would say is this is
the way we have in the United States of
your voice being heard it is not a
perfect way and I think right now the
political system in the United States is
not perfect it's not particularly high
functioning but like it this is the way
so it is vitally important that you do
it and not just I would argue on the
presidential side of things but also way
down the ballot I mean who are you going
to vote for for comptroller turns out to
be a very important and interesting
question and so take a little time to do
your research to learn about the
candidates to learn about their
positions and to learn about the parties
that they represent and and vote not
just for president but all the way down
the ballot and an interesting thing has
has happened in America because of both
gerrymandering and because people who
are more liberal
to think more nationally and people who
are more conservative tend to think more
locally that we have you know we are
entering an era where we may end up
having a lot of Democratic presidents
and a lot like a vast majority of
Republicans in local government and that
becomes a difficult country to manage it
becomes like it
it starts to feel like there are two
different forces running the country and
that that tension between local
government and national government
becomes that much more intense and that
tension is always going to exist and
it's kind of meant to exist but event
like I worry a great deal that you know
a lot of people don't think at all about
their local politics especially if they
like me live on the internet and that we
end up in a world where where where no
government gets done because all
government because state and local
government have are continually at odds
with each other yeah that's an
interesting observation I am less
I am less convinced that there is a sort
of national Democratic majority than a
lot of a lot of people are obviously
we'll see in this presidential election
cycle but I do think that I do think
that there is a disconnect for people
who live on the Internet that they don't
think about local politics the same way
that other people do and we need to we
need to think more about local politics
I think that is a huge issue
I also share your concern Hank as you
know I'm a massive fan of stability
I think stability is the most underrated
political resource and that's easy for
me to say being in a stable position of
power but but I really do I think like
government that works is extremely
important it's it's more important in
the end than like like for instance like
government that works is more important
to me than the question of whether we
should have lots of government
regulations or not that many like having
a highway bill every year which we had
for you know 55 years until this sort of
gridlock descended upon
our federal government having a highway
bill every year is really really
important more important in the end than
the highway bill being perfect and I
worry that we have moved away from
government that works toward government
that seeks to be perfect or
ideologically rigid and in that process
we have lost a big part of kind of the
United States as competitive advantage
of always being a place where we fix our
bridges at the very least I'll tell you
what man being a country that has good
bridges is incredibly underrated I have
been to a lot of countries that don't
have good bridges and it really slows
down Commerce and also everything else
it makes everything harder so here's the
good bridges this episode of your Hank
and John brought to you by good bridges
there they are underrated and lovely and
you know functional practical sometimes
gray concrete but man do we use them all
the time not only when we drive over
them but also when we buy food at the
store and today's episode of dear Hank
and John is also brought to you by pizza
messin going on now at dftba.com today's
episode of dear Hank and John is brought
to you by potato chip dust that stuff
that is somehow perfectly evenly
distributed over every single potato
chip that makes it taste just the right
amount of salt and just the right amount
of vinegar and of course today's episode
of dear Hank and John is as always
brought to you by death death the
certain consequence of licking your
fingers all right Nick one last question
this one's from daily writes Dear John
and Hank December 21st is when my son
will be born into this world I'm really
excited and cannot wait to see him and
hold him but how do I know I'm gonna be
a good dad I mean I think I will be so
my question is how do you know how to be
a good dad now you might think of his
questions more for me than for Hank but
we as it happens we both have a good dad
a really good dad and so perhaps we can
draw on some of our experience of having
had a good dad in answering this
question but as far as my own experience
being a father goes
I would say the main thing that I try to
do and I don't know if this is right or
wrong or what I don't really believe
anybody when they give parenting advice
but the main thing that I try to do is
is to love my kids and and to help them
know that they are safe when they're an
infant you know that's relatively easy
it just means holding them it means
comforting them when they cry showing
superhuman patience when they wake up at
3:30 in the morning and won't stop
crying and when I lose that patience
walking away rather than like you know
screaming at them but then as they get
older I think it's this you know for me
at least so far it's the same it's the
same thing just with a slightly more
complicated organism that I'm parenting
but I think you know it's interesting to
think about our dad Hank because I think
that both of our parents were uncommon
ly or still are uncommonly good parents
yeah I I what I felt like was that my
dad tried to help figure out who I was
and helped me figure out who I was and
that meant when I showed an interest in
something supporting that and when I you
know like when I adopted identities
being supportive of them and and and
being enthusiastic about those things
himself and wanting to be a part of the
things that I was a part of and now of
course eventually that felt like it was
overbearing and I was like ah dad you
try and always get all my stuff from too
supportive stop being so dang supportive
dad but but for the most part I really
do help but I really do feel like it
helped me figure out who I was and
become become me and become comfortable
in me and that was really important yeah
I think that's exactly right I think
both of our parents have have been that
for us they they always wanted us to
live our dreams they never wanted us to
live their dreams and they they were
always you know very supportive in us
figuring out our dreams and even when
our dreams were not typical or maybe
easy-easy dreams they were always very
supportive of them one thing I one thing
your comment reminded me of Hank is when
was going through a very rebellious
phase when I was in ninth grade III
bought the Nine Inch Nails album pretty
hate machine oh yeah a great album and
but it has a lot of explicit lyrics in
it and everything and my dad was like do
you mind if I listen to that no it's
fine man
yeah you're not gonna you're not gonna
like it it's really it's really hardcore
and my dad was into the album and
infuriating me he came into my room and
I remember he said this is so good I'm
gonna have to get my own copy it was the
most effective way to completely like
defang all of my like you know teenage
rebellious rage for him to be like you
know some of the lyrics are a little bit
provocative but I really enjoy the music
yeah I mean it is a really good album I
inherited that from you I think either
that or I ended up with Bad's yeah I
don't think dad really liked it I think
he was just proving a point all right
let's move on to the news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon Hank what is the news from
Mars this week hey John have you ever
felt like boy I want somebody to put me
on top of the largest bomb ever and and
and shoot me into outer space well NASA
is looking for its next round of
astronauts there have officially oh
there will be officially opening up
applications to become an astronaut the
qualifications are surprisingly
accessible you only need to have a BS in
a science related degree and it helps if
you have some experience flying planes
but not completely necessary and also
you will have to pass their physical
because being an astronaut is a physical
activity they will accept between eight
and twelve astronauts for this round and
those people might be the people who end
up being the astronauts who go to Mars
on the very first manned Mars missions
which would be pretty exciting which are
planned for the 2030s but you know
that's just a plan Hank are you going to
apply
oh definitely not I would not pass the
physical probably I probably couldn't
just because of coke my colitis and also
I get seasick really easily and also I
am afraid of death yeah I'm also not
going to apply I don't think that I
would make it very far in the
application process they're like how do
you feel about living with six people
for a year are you a pretty emotionally
stable person I would be like I'm out
yeah nope nope definitely not we do have
John a friend who is applying Wow that's
exciting
yeah Destin from smarter every day he is
well and he would be a great astronaut
actually he would that he's working off
hard toward that goal he wants to make
it happen that that would be so so cool
to know an astronaut would almost be
better than being an astronaut
definitely be better being an astronaut
though at the same time I that would
make me extremely nervous just I mean
less less nervous than doing it myself
but very nervous yeah agreed
I love I love Destin very much and I
also love his family can I tell you the
news from AFC Wimbledon Hank yeah go
ahead and do that
it's darkness it's no I thought you said
it was exciting no no no I was lying I
was trying to get people to make it to
the end of the podcast the truth is
darkness Oh No as you know Hank last
year AFC Wimbledon advanced to the third
round of the FA Cup where they played
Liverpool Football Club the team I've
supported since I was a kid it was an
amazing night I I flew to London to go
to the game and it was just a wonderful
thing this year that won't be happening
because AFC Wimbledon lost in the first
round of the FA Cup to a team from the
league below them called forest green
which is not even a football team it's a
colour oh no I know
Oh lost to a colour Hank they lost two
to one entirely in my opinion because
noted Montserrat II an international
Lyell Taylor did not score a goal for
the first time in several outings so you
know in some ways that
bad news I mean in fact in almost every
way it's bad news but I try to find the
silver lining and this is it this is it
this means that we can focus all of our
energy on winning Ligue 2 on advancing
up to Ligue 1 so now we don't have any
distractions we don't have any other
competitions the focus is all on the
league games this weekend for me the
past four people who are listening to
this AFC Wimbledon play probably the
biggest team in league to Portsmouth
which has a like a 20,000 seat stadium
without tens of thousands of people go
to their games every week it's really
exciting to be able to play a club like
Portsmouth so that should be a great
outing for AFC Wimbledon supporters
hopefully will get a win there very near
at the top of the table so if we can
beat a club like Portsmouth I am going
to start to think about thinking about
thinking about thinking about dreaming
so I will be only five removes from
properly dreaming about going up to
Ligue 1 so that is the news from AFC
Wimbledon well I'm sorry to hear that I
guess
yes well life is full of disappointments
large and small and you just have to
adjust to them and move on alright but
is that does that count against you
points to lose to a team so bad no
because it's a completely different
competition so it does not count for or
against points so that's good then well
it's bad because if you make it to the
third round of the FA Cup then you can
play a big team like Liverpool and you
can make more money in one day than you
make in the entire season but I see ah
but it doesn't matter because that's not
what happened so it goes all right John
well what have we learned today I mean
we've learned that hexagons are
surprisingly strong and that there is
something that Hank doesn't know we
learned that voting is stressful but
early voting it just isn't and of course
we learned that finger-lickin good is
finger-lickin dangerous now I want some
fried chicken this
has been dear Hank and John John that's
the guy who's chuckling in the
background I'm Hank
and thank you for joining us today our
theme music is by gunnarolla our podcast
is edited by the brilliant Nick Jenkins
and as we say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome and we also forgot
to say you can send us questions at Hank
and John at gmail.com or a hashtag dear
Hank and John on Twitter I'm Hank green
he's John Green but of course no one is
listening now so no one will send in
questions this week dang it nothing
nothing that was a good good good
podcast
[Music]